you know be able to tell her how to take
care of herself yeah comments like that
come to us like oh what are you gonna do
when they turn 13 because you know you
don't know you know you're not a woman
you don't know these things hey guys
we're getting a call right now
I placed my daughter for adoption at 19.
should I tell her I'm her birth mom what
do you think
based off what you know there's going to
be more information you can change your
mind after eventually yeah
yeah I mean
you'd have to ask the adopted parents I
think yes but outside of that I think
you should yeah
[Music]
but I feel like she's in the right to
know you know what I mean
yeah sure yeah yes you have to ask
because they took on when you didn't
so they have to see what the dynamic is
because they know your kid they know how
so yeah parents knows best so yeah
you're
the mother but they were the parents so
yeah I feel like there's so many factors
that go into this it's not as simple
like yes or no her name is kyohana
I read the first time kohana and I was
like damn I love Naruto too Lee Village
you know what I said oh yes sir
foreign
stop playing on my guy stop playing on
my guy
yeah so so that's that's the only
because he did some [ __ ] like that and
yeah yeah yeah and I'm I'm a real big
fan of that dude so
when he did the whole [ __ ] Death Note
[ __ ]
yeah I was like yeah bro that was old
school [ __ ] no no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you all
right yo [ __ ] you you wanna know why God
damn yeah yeah this is
right
no no no no no no no even for anime yeah
yeah don't think I don't remember yeah
okay so this Nigerian dude okay no no no
that's not because of the night Germany
I speak crail and you know and you you
gonna [ __ ] on me but this you don't even
know you're gonna be like oh oh this
[ __ ] cool now bro we're not friends calm
down hey you're not his friend are you
his friend no okay so you're on the same
level so I can do whatever the [ __ ] I
want
that [ __ ] on him we have a business
relationship though yeah cool yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I look out for
you yeah okay so what's up [ __ ] I don't
look out for you I don't have your back
you know I mean you like bikes I think
bikes are scary I'd be worried about you
I won't like no you're not shut the [ __ ]
up I swear I'd be worried oh shut up hey
bro you wanna have kids something you
got a wife you gotta be thinking of
yourself what makes you think I want to
have kids
the world deserves to preach child no
you just got baby fever calm down
but yeah I'm not gonna
yeah I told you from
you from the jumper right
used to watch it back then so I know the
death note I know the princess wanted
okay I know some bats or something some
some try gun and some some old [ __ ] and
then happened that I started [ __ ]
so I have no time to [ __ ] watch anime
and [ __ ] weed [ __ ] how much [ __ ]
are you doing
it's just a lot I'm kind of in the
middle because like if the child wants
to reach out to know their birth mom 100
I think that perhaps she should have a
conversation with the parents first and
make sure that they know and then
getting their
consent basically
I see my 11 year old daughter often and
she doesn't know I'm her birth mom she's
11. and she sees her often yeah
yeah that's a bit weird probably no it's
not weird
um it's weird because she's this one for
her
I think it's gonna be weird for the kid
when they find out yeah because they
feel like they're being lied to oh yeah
absolutely yeah but any kid
that's been adopted feels like they've
been lied to except you know the people
that don't match their parents you know
what I mean true now you you adopt a
black kid I'm like if I'm not I'm not
your real mother and I'm a kid like the
black is like what I mean you're not
adopted you're stupid you know what I
mean I think I think white parents have
to tell their kids are adopted yeah if
you don't I feel like that's just child
abuse I think I want to go over here
it's the 11th part that I'm like you I'm
like in the middle very much in the
middle because I'm coming over she's so
young and to like get thrown that
information at 11 it could
so negatively positively and I feel like
if I reveal my identity my birth
daughter could possibly have a
relationship with her half-brother my 10
month old
that was a good review well wait what do
you mean relationships you don't have it
really whatever it was a 10 month old so
she would know she has a brother
which I guess is a pretty big deal yeah
at this point does that change anyone's
Minds
being a parent and you know I went
through surrogacy but possibly I've gone
through adoption before and even when we
were going through adoption we were
always like yes we're always going to
tell this kid where they come from who
their parents are so that we can be open
and communication right but that was our
decision in the process being a parent
so these parents now who are who have
taken over the adoption they have a
right to be able to say whether or not
they want to know I moves because I'm
personally adopted and I don't know how
I would feel knowing that my birth mom
was in my life for so long and knowing I
was adopted and just like having all
those questions and just not getting the
answers and my mom lying to me so I just
feel like if you're open honest now it's
better they'll understand that it's not
traumatizing yes as like 18 and you
already got your life going exactly and
you did it for a reason I assume like I
believe my birth mom put me up for
adoption because she's going to take
care of me and I have this amazing life
now because of that decision of course
there was some resentment and like ah
you didn't want me to do that but like
when I got older and stuff I realized
that it was all for the best of me and
that's also a big thing so
kudos to you that was definitely a hard
decision I believe a little bit
hilarious is like
no I gotta shoot to Cancun how I want to
hang out chill
having a baby would have Cramp My Style
you know I'm saying something about
changing diapers keeps all the fellas
away
wouldn't that be a while there's some
dead beats out there it's like man I had
a lot more [ __ ] to do little Jimmy
why can't you have a dad cause other
[ __ ] needed this dick oh yeah I've
seen them hooplas
what this is a funny thing
as I was one interview with this guy who
like walked out on his kids
and they're like man having kids is just
a lot of energy and someone's like you
left your kid's face like yeah he's like
well then you're a deadbeat dad he's
like yeah but I'm an upbeat man and the
man just started
I got that
kids don't give a [ __ ] but I've seen
some parents and then [ __ ] yeah
sleepless nights changing diapers a lot
of Energy's invested I specifically
chose a gay couple so she has two dads
um with the intention of not having the
issue of the mother later because I knew
I wanted to be in her life
I have gotten permission from them
multiple times and was given that as
like one of the criterias of the
adoption and I am treading extremely
lightly around them and they just
continue to choose to not tell her oh
okay remember what we said about the
white mom what having a black kid yeah
and she got to tell them early yeah if
you're two gay dudes you should tell
your kid early
yeah
sorry
because she already knows Yana her mom
she knows there's someone out there so
whether you tell her she's a doctor or
not she already knows that there's a
woman out there that's her mom and she's
been hanging around her mom this whole
time so that's a different thing so it's
two dads that don't want to tell
their daughter that she had who her mom
is or that she has a mom
see
football player just yeah I think
naturally she's gonna have questions
about her mom she's getting to the age
where like she's gonna hit puberty and
be like oh you guys don't know about
periods how do I do this what female I
don't think you should say that that's
problematic yeah okay because they're
two gay guys that they won't be able to
you know be able to tell her how to take
care of herself it's not problematic
there's some things as a guy I cannot
say there's some tips and tricks I
cannot say to my daughter there's some
feelings I will never be able to that
that's just a fact
there's some things that a woman cannot
say to a boy there's some things that
you cannot comprehend walking the world
walking life with testosterone you
cannot understand that the same way I
can't understand what it's like to have
progesterone and estrogen in your body I
don't know yes you do have testosterone
but that that's a whole different all
that's an old different cocktail I
cannot know
and there's some things navigate the
world it's a different [ __ ] so you can't
be their mom any more than you could be
their school friend you're not five
anymore they need to be around kids
their age and socialize with them
because they understand each other on a
different wavelength they have fun with
each other that's why no parent can
provide their kids with everything and
certainly a man can't give a woman
everything she needs to know to go
through life the same way a woman can't
give her son everything he needs to go
through life in terms of mentorship we
have to go to other things
so yeah she's gonna have questions I
don't know to me
2K can a gay couple provide a child a
wonderful life as parents absolutely I
don't doubt that can they handle most of
the basics absolutely yeah I still need
they need a female figure somewhere
around them to be able to help them with
certain things
that's just a fact that's not some
abnormal it's like no matter how much a
man
she she contacted me about this actually
oh
um the one who's adopted and she was
saying like she said that her dad is a
gynecologist
still still
all right tell him it's not because you
show these Chinese are all of a sudden
you're Chinese no you know the language
you're not the person you're not Chinese
okay I can study a bunch of [ __ ] I can
study the dance of I'm not that I will
never be that I will never be raved as
that unless I'm raised as that and
that's that's but even even then it's
certain struggles you're just not going
to understand firsthand sometimes I want
to be with somebody who I don't have to
explain things to I want to be somewhere
where I can be understood
that's why I like there's a certain
level of comfort I feel around my black
friends that are just different from
other folks doesn't mean I can't be
friends with other groups but there's a
different understanding same with my
family there's a different understanding
a level of like knowing that they have
with me that other groups don't because
they've known a history with me that's
very unique my father provided me with
things my mom never could it is what it
is we all need these different kinds of
figures so there's nothing upsetting
about hearing the fact that
an adopted woman is saying I could have
my mother figure is a good thing
whatever I'm pretty sure like the way
like I would hope so like like putting
in a tampon you know yeah I mean that
that's what they signed up for it to
have a little girl you know to show her
how to take care of herself she saw that
she said that's true you know what
happened Hey listen my girl said that's
just problematic she said hey I don't
want to be canceled I'm gonna just let
this one go yeah yeah you saw the way
she wanted yeah you know what that's
true you know I was adopted but I'm
gonna just listen to you who wasn't
adopted okay let's go I'm curious um
what is their reason for not wanting to
um let you tell them they haven't given
me one um I've been told it will happen
multiple times it's been oh she's
starting to ask questions we should sit
down and talk about it and then when I
set up the meeting we don't discuss it
okay that that changes my mind I think
that's not fair that they're not giving
a time frame for you I'm gay and I have
a husband and I have two daughters our
two girls know everything we've told
them everything they know everything I
don't know the reason why they're not
telling her all I know is that as a gay
man who has two daughters and who are
constantly you know having uh comments
like that come to us like oh what are
you going to do when they turn 13
because you know you don't know you know
you're not a woman you don't know these
things
um I have many strong women in our lives
like my husband and I I and we're going
to lean on them when that happens but
for that 11 year old to be approached by
you and say that I'm your mom
in her eyes yes that would be fantastic
but those two guys are now going to be
looked at as someone that they that this
little girl cannot trust anymore I'm
curious I mean maybe
did
I got smoke for you did society change
ah I see what you did
I I got smoke did Society changed so
much that we're not prioritizing the
needs of the parents before the needs of
the child
he's saying well
the adopted parents like what about
their family I don't give a [ __ ] nope
this is a conversation about whether or
not the young child should know and
their feelings and their well-being
comes first last I checked Society is
supposed to be built that way that's why
we protect our kids that's why we give
our lives for our kids so when I'm
hearing this I'm like you know they're
trying to make out home girl look
problematic for what she said her being
like the adopted woman who actually went
through that experience firsthand and
instead of like really taking that [ __ ]
and trying to understand like actually
that's problematic let's focus on the
fact that two parents are I suspect it's
because it's two gay dudes and so people
are talking about that [ __ ] because it's
problematic right they're trying to be
more Pro lgbtq or whatever then just if
you think about it what's the best for
the child we're not saying you can't be
well there's just one guy that's really
trying to think like that the rest of
them are like yeah you should tell her
he's just like no what about the parents
even Jubilee is like no the Kona hot
girl she was always problematic
whatever the
village she she was the one who you
understand what I'm trying to say yes
she was the one the one the afro here
you go is that better
she was the one who was trying to say
that what she would say was problematic
I just feel like there's an emphasis on
trying to say like
it feels like they're prioritizing the
gay man's experience over the adopted
woman's experience when the whole focus
of this video is on the adopted woman's
experience absolutely I don't think
there's anything problematic with what
she said and I don't think the parents
feeling should come before what the
child eats you know what I'm saying I
feel like there's something backwards
about that am I crazy no
yeah but not for that reason okay is
that what's happening in this video or
am I missing you yeah but it's not like
it's the way I understood what you said
was that Jubilee was trying to do that
but it's really just no the girl and the
guy afro and well everyone else did
quiet
it's not because they agree it's just
because she's so
it's problematic and no but she's so
loud about it some some people that's it
they don't want confrontation no they're
like uh you know what I'm it's I agree I
am not paid enough I am not paid enough
to get canceled
it's just yeah yeah I'm not paid enough
so so they're like it's not so much that
they agree it's at the Tuesday battles
because that's not the battle that's
gonna
uh View and have a whole bunch of bad
comments on internet [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that noise I'm gonna sit this one out
this [ __ ] is lasting an hour we're
almost done yes let me let me Coast that
through so it doesn't matter that it
doesn't mean that they shut up that
they're agree with it or they just they
just chose their battle yeah yeah I I
agree but I think the fact that they
don't feel comfortable enough to speak
is also part of the issue because
they're film there's a camera you said
it yourself I agree which is what I'm
trying to say it we're even prioritizing
a gay person's feelings over the
well-being of a child yeah and we're not
speaking out because we're afraid of
being canceled well not really because
we we do not we're not having we're not
going to take a decision whether she's
gonna uh whether she's gonna actually
say it or not we're just speaking our
opinions and there's too much to lose
than to win winning that [ __ ]
argument so [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'ma shut the
[ __ ] up and go back home and then forget
about this whole thing go
because we know how the internet works
if you think about it this is a really
big I'm gonna clip you bro it looks so
bizarre to have an adopted woman saying
like yo this is what we need and they're
like well the gay adults would prefer
who gives a [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them who cares what matters in this
whole scenario is her
what is the 11 year old need and the
idea that they would stop trusting she
the young daughter would stop trusting
her parents because they can tell what
are things gonna happen if they wait
till they're 18 it's not gonna be better
it's not what you could think it's gonna
happen you you ain't talking about this
woman I've known my whole life I've
wondered about because apparently she's
been asking questions right according to
the man's own the one's own words she's
been asking questions about who her
parents are who's her mom you've been
hiding it this whole time
she's 11. she's 11 she's not stupid no
it's gonna be even worse if she finds
out by herself absolutely she can shut
everybody down yes sir two parents the
mom every [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you everybody out here so it's not
better I agree my dominance because I
gave up that right and I gave them the
the option to choose which women they
want in their lives to fill that kind of
motherly role I'm adopted if my birth
mom came to me and was like I'm your
mother and my parents knew and didn't
tell me first that's where I feel like
the distrust would come from do you feel
like you want to be her mother again is
that like part of your intention no I
I'm a huge Ally and I chose gay dads
Because I knew that they would be I knew
that she would be loved like
what I wasn't able to do at the time
thank you for that and um awesome yeah
but I don't have their perspective at
all I'm an assist
heterosexual woman and I I haven't gone
through any of anything that they've
gone through the mother no then shut
your ass up please
that's facts At first she said she chose
two gay dudes because she didn't want a
mom to be in the way so she can come in
back in the future now she's trying to
say I chose to gay dance because I'm an
ally
girl if you don't get the [ __ ] up out of
here is that how people are really
choosing parents now for their adopted
kids yeah because women are very I love
the lgbtq can I get three lesbians
please like what are we talking about
right now you owe it to her to be honest
and to be trust and to be patient and
you owe it to them to be patient you
know it's been 11 years I think you can
be patient a little longer and let the
dads do it on their time they said that
they will and I think that should be
respected
foreign
yes
would have been hilarious she said
carefully deliberated and
I understand and I think I should be
responsible to the gay guys but [ __ ]
them [ __ ] hey hey what up little baby
I'm your mama
just like this strike a b-boy post you
know what I'm saying
let's find out actually I have no idea
what's gonna happen no that would be a
hilarious organization she's not gonna
say [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I actually agree with the notion that
probably should be a discussion between
everyone it was just interesting
watching the conversation unfold and how
it nominated the way it was but I don't
think the gaming was entirely wrong
about what he was trying to say it's
just interesting that at first it was
just like oh what about the Trust In how
the parents feel the gay man I'm like
who cares
and how long would this does she have to
wait did you say you have to wait a few
more years how long are we talking
um
that's absolutely true that's actually
true
so check on the child
you don't know like I said that before
we don't know what the child is what the
state of mind how fragile that child is
whatever you need to assess that be a
parent be a [ __ ] parent you're
like disagree here's why I disagree go
ahead they're gay
if it was a strict cup I would feel
differently it's great it's even crazier
if if it's if it's not even gay people
because your school that's cool you're
gonna know you're gonna see you're gonna
see what your education that you know
babies come from men and women if it's
actually biological like what my
biological but if it's like a man and a
woman being the parent being the author
it's even worse because the kid can not
suspect at all and live thinking they
mom they dead and then they just ask
questions Mom and Dad whatever blah blah
blah live their life and eventually oh
[ __ ] I'm a doctor
the feeling is that your whole life is a
whole lie worse than if it's just gay
people you know what hey guys we're
getting a call right now
let's listen in
yo I want to ask you a question okay so
as an adopted child if you got two
scenarios you just tell us what you
think would be worse or better right are
your parents white oh
yeah my parents are white if you're okay
there's a question if your parents have
been black do you think you would have
needed to know early
because
because built with that and then if you
learn at 18 you're like damn my whole
life was alive what else have they been
lying about all this stuff but if they
tell you early on it's like open trust
and you just like love them as your
parents and then you can also just I
don't know I was told I don't even
remember being told
also it's like my parents are white I'm
black so there's that you already know
that nobody needs to tell you already
know you're adopted yeah yeah right I'm
sure they
know that we chose you it was always
like the
the narrative
shows you we wanted you to be
our family like
teen I would feel so betrayed I'd have
so many questions me personally I feel
like
I would have like trust issues with them
let's say you're you have white parents
and they tell you you're adopted but
they don't say who who adopted you
um what would that be like for you nah
that's that's a red flag
I'd be like why right see I would be
like why and then I'd be like have the
insecurity that
believe
parents so that they don't believe that
I would think that they're my parents or
so there's like an insecurity there okay
which is a red flag it's interestingly
enough I feel like your situation is
kind of analogous to the other situation
with the the gay parents only because
um from my perspective whether it's you
or that young girl both of you guys know
that your parents aren't like your
biological parents so whether they tell
the person or not like the kid already
knows so I feel like withholding who
that is isn't that like pretty harmful
to some degree
okay 100
you have to know where
you come from and if the parents have
negative things to say on the birth
parent to the kid yeah
a parent gave life to you that's one
that's like a gift you know and they
should not be [ __ ] on the birth
parent to the kid because like I feel
like
there's something in there that would
harm the kid and have like a negative
like I don't know I just feel like
that's harmful in some way and I feel
like also withholding that information
makes it seem like adoption is bad yeah
oh speak on that speak on that
it's like you
've like a negative
it's such a beautiful process you chose
me you wanted me like yeah just it's
just like such a beautiful thing and it
should be well when it goes right yeah I
get used to just the idea of being
Chosen and wanted by somebody when when
somebody else doesn't like it is a
beautiful thing that they will take you
in like family
yeah successful adoption stories are
very beautiful well listen I appreciate
you uh calling in was really good for
the perspective so thank you
all right we will yeah cause you're
problematic yeah yeah yeah we're coming
for you yo yo
Yo No but no but my mom mama
that was yeah I feel like you kind of
shut down after that [ __ ]
and I
I'm just saying that it's like different
to hear
a man talk about it because they can
only learn so much from like
internet
a woman going or someone with a
budget you know
it's just different they know the
feelings they don't they they know the
emotions that go with it they can relate
to you on that level and that's all I
was saying
yeah I appreciate you guys have fun
filming editing or whatever you're doing
now all right peace
[Laughter]
hey guys we're getting a call right now
that that's the thing is that you know
it's not because I eat muscles that I
know yeah
the feeling of a muscle is
I don't know how it is to be an oyster
you know I just I just know I eat them
yeah yeah but it was interesting it was
a cool video so let us know what you
guys think we want to hear from you guys
in the comments below if you guys agree
disagreed you feel like we were unfair
we want to hear from you guys anything
else boom peace